have a great sound effects designer here
at the show named rob olent okay he does
a great job that's him
here's the reason i'm bringing him up
unfortunately and this is a true story i
come into work today
and my producer jeff ross right over
there uh said uh there he is wow that
guy that's all right yeah
wow
this guy
that guy lights up a room well anyway uh
well his policy of insisting there
always be a camera on him really paid
off
unfortunately so jeff comes up to me he
goes like i got to talk to you come into
my office we got to talk
and i said i can't even understand what
you're saying and he's like i just had
some soup it was good soup
and he says come into my office i got to
speak to you so i go into jeff's office
and he says you know we just got one
issue it's not a big deal but rob the
sound effects guy couldn't make it into
work today true story he's fine but the
rear window of his car got smashed in
and he's been busy taking care of it and
so he called in and said i can't be at
work today
and so jeff said i'm just telling you we
have no sound effects today so that's
we're not going to do any comedy that
has sound effects and i was like this is
[ __ ]
right
[ __ ] i want to have what if i want
sound effects why can't i make the sound
effects myself uh-oh why do i need to
they gave me the setup that he uses i've
not used it before i'm just looking at
it but it's got some cool stuff here and
they've got some labels here like uh i
think we've got a good show tonight
[Applause]
oh pretty cool uh the audience didn't
like the fact that i just replaced it
all right right
oh boo me will you well guess what i'll
boo you
yeah
andy would you like a bite of an
invisible sandwich why certainly i would
andy you better swallow that sandwich
[Applause]
[Applause]
it says creek but it's it's kind of
farty it's kind of
it's a little i swear to god it says
creek right there i don't do that kind
of low right when when bryce styles
howard sits down you know then you hit
that
it says creek it doesn't say that
man if she did that i think i'd fall in
love with her
[Laughter]
this one says oh uh i think this makes
like a dramatic tell me something give
me some bad news andy some dramatic all
right an asteroid's hurtling towards the
earth
[Music]
[Applause]
it's only as big as a pee though
[Applause]
[Applause]
hello ladies
there's a dog in here
there's a dolphin oh yeah dog and
dolphin
uh oh what if the dog
falls in love
with the dolphin
oh
and they have a baby
an abomination baby
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
i love you conan
and i want to try this one i love you
conan
she's holding my baby
i think i know what this one is for
entourage didn't do so well at the box
office but we have this
[Laughter]
[Applause]
all right that's fun that is a lot of
fun all right i think there's a reason
though that they have professionals do
yeah i think so